do you believe in ghosts do you believe
that disembodied spirits
can communicate with us from the
afterlife do you believe that human
souls can get caught somewhere between
this world and whatever comes next
i don't but if scientists suddenly had
definitive proof of souls or spirits or
an afterlife
i'd be totally on board excited about it
even oh i'm coming back to haunt you
after you flush me
flush you i'm gonna batter and fry you
you sick son of a [__] even though i'm
skeptical about the paranormal
i'm still interested i love spooky stuff
i've been to the lorry mansion in new
orleans which had a dark and brutal
history
even before nicolas cage lived there
i've tried to summon princess tuscawanta
the broken-hearted lady of lake
ronkonkoma who has claimed the lives of
120 swimmers
all young men i've even held a seance
with gene simmons while chasing ghosts
around the queen mary uh now you're just
making things up
i picture closing every show with the
seance like this
okay i didn't see that coming the queen
mary really was super creepy and you can
check it out for yourself you go down to
long beach california and they will show
you around
and we've got 10 more spooky places that
you can actually visit
coming up whether you're into ghosts or
just like the darker side of history
this video is for you
welcome to the y files where high iq
folks like us come to laugh and learn
and if you're enjoying the content do us
a favor and hit the like button which is
kind of this shape and the subscribe
button which is kind of like a red
rectangle is that the shape hit those
they really help out the channel
scariest places in the world that's a
list that's been done
a million times but the problem i have
with those lists
is they're inaccessible the places are
either closed to the public or a million
miles away
i mean there's no scarier place on earth
than la isla de las vegas
speak english madonna island of the
dolls gracias
but unless you live near mexico city and
can get special permission
youtube is as close as you're going to
get instead here's a list of the
scariest places in the u.s
open to the public right now some offer
tours
some will let you wander around on your
own some will even let you spend the
night now this list is just going to
cover the states but for
our wi filers in the uk there are lots
of haunted places in your neck of the
woods
so many that they need their own video
if you'd like us to do one just request
that in the comment section
heckle fish you ready dude i've been
ready since i was caviar
i'll take that as a yes eastern state
penitentiary
eastern state penitentiary in
philadelphia was once the most
famous prison in the world known for its
grand architecture
and strict discipline it was operational
from 1829
until 1971 and was home to thousands of
inmates
including big names like al capone and
willie sutton considered to be one of
the most haunted places in america
there have been reports of echoing
voices shadowy figures ghostly faces
stories that have been corroborated by
staff guards
visitors even other inmates while they
were serving time
its history makes it easy to imagine the
spirits of troubled souls
wandering the gloomy halls it was the
world's first
actual penitentiary a prison designed to
inspire
penitence or true regret in the hearts
of the convicted
the mad chair bound a prisoner's limbs
so
tightly that circulation was cut off
requiring eventual amputation
the iron gag is where an inmate's hands
were tied behind his back
and an iron collar forced into his mouth
so that any movement at all
caused the tongue to rip and bleed and
in some cases just be torn right out of
his face
the hole was an underground cell where
prisoners had
no light no toilet no exercise
no human contact and barely enough food
to stay alive
solitary confinement was eventually
phased out as the prison population grew
by 1926
there were over 1700 inmates living
three
sometimes four to a cell cells designed
to just hold one
in 1933 inmates rioted because of
overcrowding and they set fire to cells
all over cell block 12 which is now
a focal point of paranormal activity
people have heard cell doors opening and
closing
some say they can smell smoke others
have even said they've seen shadowy
figures walking through the catwalk
if you want to experience eastern state
for yourself you can
they run day and night tours called
terror behind the walls
no thank you link in the description
below
trans-allegheny lunatic asylum the
trans-allegheny lunatic asylum
later known as weston state hospital was
a psychiatric hospital that operated
from
1864 through 1994 in western west
virginia
it comprises 13 buildings on 666 acres
of property
that doesn't sound like an accident the
trans-allegheny lunatic asylum
originally intended to be a place of
peace and recuperation for the mentally
ill
but it quickly devolved into a nightmare
of abuse suffering and human atrocity
designed to house 250 patients the
population eventually swelled to over
2600 people
rooms that were intended for one
occupant often contained five or six
people crammed together sleeping on the
floor to make matters worse
trans allegheny began admitting the
criminally insane
and letting them mingle with the rest of
the patient population
this was not a good idea violent
patients that couldn't be controlled
were locked in cages in the common areas
as recently as the 80s
the 1880s the 1980s the 1980s
ronald reagan mtv and people in cages
what a decade
a 1938 report found that the hospital
housed
epileptics alcoholics drug addicts
and non-educable mental defectives it
sounds a lot like hollywood
oh things get even more gruesome famous
dr walter freeman set up shop here to
perform experimental lobotomies
for his procedure dr freeman used the
ice pick method
i'm afraid to ask he slipped a metal rod
into the patient's eye socket
then used a mallet to hammer the rod
through the thin bone
and sever the tissue in the prefrontal
cortex over the course of his career
dr freeman did over 4 000 lobotomies
sometimes leaving perfectly healthy
patients with permanent brain damage
still sounds like hollywood by the way
dr freeman did this procedure without
gloves
without anesthesia without surgical
training oh
fine i'd rather have a bottle in front
of me than a frontal lobotomy
oh that old gym i got a million of them
the trans-allegheny lunatic asylum was
forced to close in 1994
and it's like the patients just vanished
into thin air
rooms still contain furniture artwork
medical equipment
there's wheelchairs in the hallways i
don't know why that's extra scary but it
is
one of trans-allegheny's well-known
ghosts is a little girl named lily
who was born lived and died right there
in the asylum
and has haunted it ever since it's been
reported
that lily likes to hold visitors hands
and tug on their clothes
some people have heard her giggling and
playing in the hallway near her first
floor room
doors are often left open by elizabeth a
nurse who doesn't know she's dead
supposedly she's still making her rounds
other reported ghosts belong to patients
who were brutally killed there
were killed themselves and there were
lots of those when you go to their rooms
reports say that the air gets cold and
you can hear whispers or voices in your
ear in 2007 trans allegheny opened to
the public
they offered day night and overnight
tours the most frequent visitors are
ghost hunters
but for anyone interested in the dark
history of america
the trans-allegheny lunatic asylum is a
must-see
[Music]
the whaley house the whaley house in old
town san diego
has been called the most haunted house
in america it's been documented in books
magazines tv for over 100 years
if there are ghosts at the whaley house
who are they
and what do they want in 1852 james
yankee jim robinson
was convicted of larceny and hanged on
the property present at the hanging
was thomas whaley he bought the property
and built a house there
in 1857 he moved his family in
and that's where it all started thomas
whaley was successful in almost every
venture he pursued
until he built the whaley house after
that tragedy haunted him and his family
for the rest of his life
thomas's son thomas jr contracted
scarlet fever when he was 18 months old
and died shortly thereafter in 1858 a
few months later
an arsonist set fire to whaley's
business despondent over these tragedies
the family moved to san francisco
briefly but were forced back
when an earthquake devastated their home
out of money and out of options
thomas whaley went on the road and
traveled the country looking for
employment
unsuccessfully meanwhile his family was
back in san diego in dire straits
thomas whaley's daughter violet married
and then divorced a local cod man
her humiliation caused her such despair
that she took her own life in the whaley
house in 1885
she was only 22 years old thomas whaley
passed away from poor health in 1890 his
wife anna his son francis his son george
and daughter lillian all eventually died
in the whaley house
the house was converted into a museum in
1960 and immediately workers
staff guests visitors all reported
hearing voices
smelling cigars smelling perfume and
seeing ghostly apparitions
look i'm just telling a story believe it
or not but in 1964
famous tv personality regis philbin went
to film a local broadcast at the whaley
house and he left there convinced
that he saw the ghost of anna whaley and
years later regis went back to the house
still convinced to his dying day he
always said
something is going on in this house i
trust regis
i do too i also trust the multiple
police officers
who over the course of 30 years
witnessed a woman crying at the back of
the house
one officer kept quiet about this but
after he retired
he wrote that he also found a woman
crying at the back of the house
he said she was dressed in period
clothing he asked her
ma'am are you all right she then looked
at him and smiled when he turned his
flashlight on her
she disappeared was the woman anna
whaley crying over the loss of her
children or was it violent
crying because she regretted taking her
own life there's a link below where how
you can go visit the whaley house
and find out for yourself lake
shawnee amusement park the lake shawnee
amusement park is located in princeton
west virginia west virginia again huh
interesting the park opened in 1926 to
cater to the families of nearby coal
workers but all that remains is its
skeleton
which is appropriate given its dark
history the land in which the park is
built
was home to a native american tribe when
the clay family attempted to settle the
land in 1783
a turf war ensued which resulted in the
brutal deaths of both natives and
settlers alike
all buried on the site centuries later a
local businessman
purchased the clay property and built a
swing set ferris wheel and a swimming
pond
and all three of those attractions would
claim one child's life lake shawnee
eventually expanded into a full
amusement park
and was responsible for at least six
deaths it finally closed in 1966
however all the structures rides and
attractions they're still standing
rusted
and overgrown and creepy as on the
property is a
motorized swing machine and many years
ago a little girl was killed climbing
into one
in a horrible way anyway the current
owner of the property says that even
when there's no wind
he can still see those swings kind of
moving and creaking
and when he gets close to that swing
where the girl died he feels a chill in
the air
and says he can hear whispers okay fine
whispers
wind no big deal but the owner's son
said that he's seen a vision
of a little girl wearing a pretty dress
covered in blood
paranormal investigators have been all
over this site because
lake shawnee's been featured on all the
ghost hunter tv shows and youtube and
everywhere but you don't need press
credentials or a positron collider to
visit lake shawnee amusement park
it's open to the public day night and
even for overnight camping
flashlights are mandatory but you might
not like what you see
good luck the abandoned cincinnati
subway
oh i love this one now early in the 20th
century cincinnati was the 10th largest
city in america
trade was primarily conducted using a
complicated canal system
which just couldn't keep up with demand
many canals became filthy and had to be
drained and refilled
which led to mosquitoes which led to
disease it was a mess a plan was made to
build a 16-mile rail system
partially underground work began in 1920
but it was hit with all kinds of delays
houses along the route were crumbling
foundations cracked porches falling into
holes in the earth
lawsuits budget cuts and city corruption
crippled the project
two miles of the underground tunnel were
completed by 1929
but then the stock market crashed and
the great depression hit and the project
was put on the shelf so you're saying
the train
project was derailed really puns
no you're not giving me much to work
with here fair enough
in 1962 at the height of the cold war
the abandoned liberty street station was
converted into a community fallout
shelter
areas were designated as first aid rooms
kitchens
decontamination showers even a morgue
some of the equipment and furnishings
are still down there
an open house was held for the citizens
of cincinnati who were
not impressed the tunnels kind of just
sat there
they were officially decommissioned in
1991 and the entrances to the tunnels
sealed
but not all entrances disclaimer time
yes
you can get into the tunnels no you're
technically not allowed to do that
you can request a tour but the city
rarely grants access
this hasn't stopped paranormal
investigators or urban explorers from
seeking out the hidden access points
which as of this video still exist links
below
city wickenburg arizona is about 70
miles northwest of phoenix
and it's home to vulture city an
abandoned ghost town that sits on top of
vulture mine
and if there's a list of haunted places
in america
vulture mine is always on it in 1863
austrian prospector henry wickenburg
discovered a gold deposit that would
become the most productive gold mine in
arizona history
by the 1880s the settlement's population
exploded making it one of the most
densely populated areas in the southwest
and the success of the mine accelerated
arizona's bid for statehood
however after just a few short years the
gold dried up
and the place was abandoned but during
its height over 5 000 people lived in
vulture city
and when the gold and greed are flowing
that's going to attract dangerous people
looking for a quick score there was so
much violent crime and corruption in
vulture city
that the united states army was called
in to keep the peace
they weren't able to instead justice was
meted out by vigilante citizens
and there was no worse crime in vulture
city than steel and gold
if you were caught you got done strung
up on a hanging tree
dozens of vulture cities worst were hung
from the ironwood tree that still stands
today
if you met your end of the hanging tree
you did not merit a burial in the
cemetery
your body was buried on the spot bodies
that are still feeding that tree today
vulture city was a place where a few
made a fortune but
many suffered and died men women
children
violence was common as was illness
hundreds of bodies are supposedly buried
not just in the cemetery but all around
the town
oh did it just get cold in here the
reports of cold spots
eerie voices disembodied spirits have
attracted ghost hunters from all over
the world
some say workers who were buried alive
can be heard
screaming and trying to claw their way
out of their rocky tomb
if you're in the phoenix area you can
take a guided tour of vulture mine
or you can explore on your own links
below
ohio state reformatory the ohio state
reformatory
also known as the mansfield reformatory
is a historic prison
located in mansfield ohio it opened its
doors in 1896 as a true reformatory it
emphasized
incentive over punishment inmates were
admitted for
18 months they were given education they
were taught a trade
and they were released this model had a
very high success rate and most inmates
went on to lead productive lives
so you know this whole thing's gotta go
pear-shaped osr was originally supposed
to house two thousand inmates
one per cell but by 1934 the prison was
so overcrowded
that they had two and sometimes three
prisoners per cell
crammed together when you put dangerous
people in close quarters
deprive them of food and exercise you
create a recipe for violence
according to the prisons website just as
animals in the wild had to learn to
adapt and survive in their surroundings
so did the occupants of the osr shanks
shivs and all kinds of improvised
weapons were found in
every crevice of the cells fun fact if
this prison looks familiar
that's because it is shawshank
redemption was shot at osr in the
description i'll link you to a video
that shows all the different filming
locations
if you're a fan of the movie it's a must
watch and things that osr just got worse
in the 1960s it was converted into a
maximum security prison to house the
most dangerous criminals in the state
violence escalated and in those dark
years over 200 people died at osr
guards staff and inmates life at osr was
so frightening
that inmates often took their own lives
others tried to escape
some even succeeded lester eubanks was
sent to osr in 1965 for crime
so heinous i won't repeat them here but
i'll link below
for those of you that are into gruesome
stuff anyway eubanks escaped custody in
1973 and hasn't been seen since
he's still on the u.s marshal's top 10
most wanted list
by the 1980s the conditions were so bad
that the inmates got together a
class-action lawsuit
and sued the state of ohio for putting
them through brutalizing and inhumane
conditions they won the suit the prison
closed
wanted you bet your flippers it is there
are reports of doors slamming
people being pushed scratched equipment
being turned on and off
and these stories drew a lot of interest
from the ghost hunting community who
consider it one of the scariest places
on earth
now if you want to check it out for
yourself osr offers
all kinds of different tours historical
and paranormal they host
private paranormal investigation tours
they even teach ghost hunting classes
and if you want to be truly petrified
you need to sign up for the escape from
blood prison experience
where your goal is to escape while being
chased by actors dressed as guards
prisoners and ghosts
at least i hope they're actors the
mineral springs hotel
alton illinois is known as the most
haunted small town in america
and the focal point of the spiritual
disturbance is the mineral springs hotel
when the mineral springs hotel and spa
opened in 1914
it was spectacular five floors of
luxurious accommodations
a marble staircase and the largest
swimming pool in the state
a natural spring was found on the
property and the water had
a high sulfur content which gave it kind
of a funky smell
well an enterprising chemist said that
that water had
magical healing properties and naturally
before you know it
they're shipping hundreds of bottles a
day of sulfur water
all around the country that's a lot of
diarrhea the hotel eventually declined
and fell into disrepair like all of us
but in 1978
mineral springs was renovated and now
contains an
antique mall some offices apartments
even a horror museum even though mineral
springs was a famous luxury hotel
it's now really famous for being a
paranormal hotspot
one of the staircases is a specific
focus point the story goes that a young
woman brought a man to her room
a man who was not her husband but the
husband got back to the room early
and found his wife and another guy
uh how do i say this without getting in
trouble on youtube
in flagrante delecto
right that so an argument ensued
and spilled out into the hallway now we
don't know if it was an accident or if
she was pushed
but the wife died at the bottom of those
stairs now investigators say that they
can smell jasmine in the hallway
she was wearing jasmine perfume when she
died and that ghost is now known as the
jasmine lady
and ghosts are all over this property in
the bottling room people have reported
seeing the figure of a tall
slender man and the lower levels contain
the swimming pools
where multiple people had drowned over
the years some of those deaths are
actually recorded and verified
during a recent tour wet footprints were
found even though the pool has been
drained for years
the pool room doors have been known to
open and close on their own
and many tourists have described hearing
and feeling
someone's breath on their neck yikes
fort delaware state park fort delaware
is a fortress on p patch island in the
delaware river
originally built to protect wilmington
and philadelphia it became
infamous as a pow camp for confederate
soldiers during the civil war
thirty three thousand soldiers were
imprisoned there and almost three
thousand of them died from dysentery
scurvy smallpox and they're buried in a
mass grave in new jersey and that
explains the smell
the man in charge of fort delaware was
general alvin schuff
who became known as general terror with
thousands of prisoners kept in
makeshift wooden barracks the conditions
were horrible bed bugs lice and vermin
infested the buildings
food rations were tiny and inedible
decaying bodies and human waste caused
the water to putrefy
these men were starving and dying of
thirst a favorite game of the guards was
called
ratcall this is where rat holes were
flooded and then the rats were caught
and killed
a guard would yell ratcall and then toss
the dead rats into the crowd
and according to an inmate's diary the
prisoners scrambled for the rats like
schoolboys for apples
he goes on to say that the rats were
cleaned boiled and then fried their
flesh was tender and not unpleasant to
the taste
that's a dude who is starving the diary
is from captain john s swann who was
captured in 1864.
he chronicles the terrifying daily life
as a confederate prisoner of war
it's fascinating reading link where it
is for civil war history fans fort
delaware is an incredible place where
daily life is recreated but the real
draw to fort delaware
ghosts with so much death and suffering
it's no wonder that fort delaware is
considered one of the most haunted
places on earth
ghost tours are given all the time and
you could even enjoy an
escape the island experience visitors
claim that ghosts can be seen on a daily
basis
in the dungeons halls and rooms voices
can be heard
photographs have been taken that show
everything from orbs of light all the
way up to
what seemed like ghostly figures there's
also the story of a nine-year-old
drummer boy who tried to escape the
prison by hiding in a coffin the escape
failed
he was buried alive and the story goes
he still haunts the grounds playing his
drum
and crying for help waverly hill
sanatorium
the waverly hills sanatorium in
louisville kentucky
is a highly active paranormal
investigation site
waverly hills opened in 1910 to treat
tuberculosis patients
but by 1911 they were overflowing and
they had to build tents to accommodate
all the new patients
thousands of them it's been estimated
that 64
000 people died at waverly and their
bodies are buried on the property but
there are no headstones
we don't know where the bodies are but i
promise you that they're down there
somewhere
so many people died at waverly hills
they had to use something that they
called a death
shoot which was a tube-like tunnel they
would use to haul
packages and groceries and supplies up
shoot bodies down
the death shoot is reported to be
haunted by those who made their final
journey
through the tunnel definitely worst
roller coaster ever another haunted area
is room 502
which is designated for nurses one of
them hanged herself in there
another jumped out a window another went
in there and
never came out she's just gone
502. go for it there are ghosts of
children named bobby and mary
that reportedly roam the halls searching
for their mommy
what do you think doctor are you my
mummy that's creepy
in the early 1960s waverly hills was
converted into a nursing home but it was
eventually closed in the 1980s for
you guessed it patient abuse geez this
thing is like a ghost making factory
waverly hills became known outside the
area when it was profiled on the tv
series
scariest places on the earth since then
it's become a popular destination for
paranormal investigators
according to the waverly hills
historical society guided tours and
overnight stays are available but you
need to book over a year in advance
if you want to visit i've got a link
below thanks for hanging out with us
today my name is aj
that's hecklefish this has been the
y-files do you know of any scary places
that are open to the public
put them in the comments section so we
can check them out we work really hard
on these videos for you so if you
enjoyed them
kindly do us a favor and give us a
thumbs up it really helps out the
channel
if you're new here i hope you earned
your subscription today but if we didn't
i promise we'll keep making fun brainy
content until we do earn it until next
time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]